There are two things in this world that I'm the best at,...
...being a professional barista and being an unlicensed therapist.
If I can do them at the same time, why wouldn't I?
I do things that real therapists can't.
I'm too old for this stool.
Get me out of here!
You're welcome.
I listen with my eyes, and I heal with my hands.
They come for the brownies, but they stay because there are pills in them.
Secret recipe.
I love my job.
I get to be a therapist without all the boring parts.
Pouring coffee is beneath me.
I have a higher calling.
Have you heard about the healing powers of shock therapy?
No, what's it about?
I'm the baristapist, and you don't need a license for that...
...except for the one that I embroider.